hey guys I'm Abby char welcome to Abby's
kitchen and I am here with my friend Sam
from Sam core trainer.com so we're gonna
chat a little bit about pelvic health
and getting our bodies kind of back into
a state where we're ready to exercise
again after giving birth so thanks so
much for joining you today Sam thank you
so much for having me so Sam let's go
back to like pregnancy stage what is
really important for moms who are about
to give birth or in that pregnancy phase
to get them prepared for after birth to
get back into shape okay so I have a
motto that really the best time for you
to prepare for your recovery is while
you're still pregnant
because a lot of women think okay during
my pregnancy with the extra cautious and
I will worry about getting back into
shape after I have my baby when I have
all that extra time yeah so much time
yeah yeah no time so it really I say
while the babies in utero while all
these significant changes are happening
you really want to be able to manage
those changes by staying strong staying
healthy relief at any time you should be
exercising it's when you're pregnant
I love that it's when you're growing a
human because really at the end of the
day the healthier the host the healthier
the outcome that's the right point yeah
um and you're also able to like your
body is able to get strong and then
you're creating that muscle memory so
then when you go back to exercise you're
not going up hill your body knows it's
like oh I'm familiar with this I know
how to do that so it's it's really a
better way to do it as while you're
pregnant and then it makes your recovery
that much more successful that's a
really good point
you know a lot of people have this
misconception that they can't exercise
while they're pregnant or there's
dangers affiliated is there any truth to
that no if you know the World Health
Organization actually recommends whether
you're pregnant or not 150 minutes per
week of moderate-intensity exercise so
that is more than walking your dog okay
it is more than yoga now walking your
dogs very good and yoga especially in
the leaders together
Yoga is awesome but you really do want
to get that heart rate up
to adopt and everybody is different kind
but you want to get that heart rate up
because you're really preparing for an
event like no weather leave my god first
marathon manage exactly so you wouldn't
not do anything and then wake up and
then tomorrow I'm gonna go run a
marathon right you want to prepare your
body it's the same thing in pregnancy
you want to prepare so yes you want to
continue to do cardiovascular exercise
so you have the endurance to last
hopefully a short labor and not here 20
hours right here baby
so I have to build up the endurance but
you also need to build the strength
right so you're gonna you want to keep
moving during your labor you might be
doing a lot of squatting you need a lot
of abdominal strength lot more strength
to push that baby out and because you
are gaining on average 25 to 35 pounds
it might be more depending on all sorts
of things that's a lot of stress on your
ligaments and everything in your bit in
your body so the stronger you are that
could be easier you're able to actually
carry around the extra weight load so
you really want to strengthen as well as
do cardiovascular exercise during a good
night for sure okay so bottom line to my
pregnant mom is out there keep up the
exercise it's good for you and it's good
for baby yes
now let's talk about after we push the
baby out what is important for moms to
know when it comes to what are the first
things that they should be looking at
and doing you want to be aware of what
has happened to your core and especially
your pelvic floor right so I would say
the first thing is do you feel any
heaviness do you feel any pressure right
and we also want to talk about the
importance of pelvic health because I
would say that is your first line of
defense and making sure that you have a
healthy recovery right because I mean
I'm sure a lot of Mama's can appreciate
the peeing situation is is hard right
like walking down a hill you're probably
gonna pay yourself for the first little
bit so we want to avoid that that's
embarrassing um and so it's not just
about of course getting our ABS back
together and making sure we have that
six-pack right away but like you said
like it's really about kind of starting
with the pelvic floor and talk about yes
yes right here we love the model to give
you an idea so this is your pelvis okay
and everybody's pelvis is size
differently and shape differently but if
we look at these red things right here
these are all the muscles of the pelvic
floor so the your pelvic floor muscles
start at the front of your pubic bone
they go right under they attach right
here and then your sit bones okay some
real yoga people they know what your
stick bones aren't and it goes right on
the bottom and it attaches on the bottom
of your spine so your pelvic floor
muscles and there's several layers in
here and inside here in the bowl and
this is where the baby is is going
through into sitting in the pelvis and
exits your vagina this is where your
uterus your bladder and your rectum live
right okay so before pregnancy your
pelvic floor supports about two to three
pounds on average put a baby in there
and everything else now all of a sudden
it's supporting 25 35 40 pounds whatever
it is right and then your muscles here
so this is your fear this is your vagina
these muscles get stretched all the way
and this is your perineum that's all get
stretched in order to birth right after
your baby comes out the muscle devotion
no nice husband's would like to think
that to be the case it takes a while so
all of these muscles here really not
only support your uterine organs but
they also help support your pelvis and
your spine
that's a very important group of muscles
because we want to make sure we keep our
organs in place and we also like you're
saying about the peeing a lot of women
have sociate it's normal to be because
I've had babies wanting to pee
yeah right I'm glad that right after
birth you might have some leaking for a
little while yeah we want to minimize
okay yeah but we want to minimize that
and I would really say you want to get
on top of doing your pelvic floor
exercises right doing your kegels but
also having said that not everybody
should do people's either oh because our
muscles our nerve pelvic floor like
every other muscle in their body so if
you have a muscle that's too tight so if
I were to walk around like this hmm
would you give me a bicep curl yeah no
no because you're really here Yeah right
I need to do this right I can do this if
somebody is leaking a lot and their
pelvic floor they might walk around all
the time grit they're doing kegels all
the time because they don't want to lean
their pants and now they've created a
muscle that what we call is hypertonic
because it's so tight and so if anything
what they should be doing they should be
releasing it should be doing reverse
kegels but how do you know you need to
get assessed you have to see a pelvic or
physiotherapist so the public floor
physiotherapist is a regular
physiotherapist who's gone back to get
extensive training in pelvic health and
so they will actually do an internal
assessment they'll see where your
muscles are @rv too tight are they're
too loose we want to get there we want
to see if there's been any tearing on
the inside from birth if you've had an
episiotomy or you if you've had any
tearing externally that's different but
you also might have internal tears and
how is the strength are you able to do a
Kegel right and how is the level of
strength you might be able to do a Kegel
but can you hold it right if not or or
if you can't do a Kegel okay then we got
to work on it or if you're doing too
many
Eagles so there's so many things to
learn and quite honestly after you see a
pelvic or physio women are like oh my
god I've learned so much about my vagina
yeah one of the big things that a lot of
people talk about pre and post of
pregnancy is this diastasis recti or
wreck tire however you want to say it
can you talk a little bit about that how
do you identify that you have this issue
what's normal and of course how do we
heal it because I think a lot of moms
are super concerned I know I was really
worried about the separation of those
ABS so first of all what is dice days
okay so diastasis recti the anatomical
term is actually for separation of the
rectus abdominis diastasis separation
and then recti is a rectus abdominis so
you've got three layers of abdominals
you've got your deepest ones ones I was
talking about your transverse then
you've got your obliques in the middle
and then you've got that six-pack on top
is your rectus abdominus and what
happens is before you even become
pregnant your rectus abdominus muscles
are not fused together they're not like
this they're kept together by connective
tissue called the Linea Alba okay so if
you look online and look at any Anatomy
illustration you will see like there's a
line here and then you'll see the
various muscles yeah
so that's your Linea Alba the pelvis the
front of the pelvis this is connective
tissue that keeps in front of the pelvis
together it's about anything with our
runs its abdominis because there's a
reptile insert in the front of the
pelvis so what happens is with the
influences of hormones and as this
uterus grows the connective tissue
starts to stretch sideways that it fills
and it stretches sideways to make space
for baby
right it is the most normal part of
pregnancy yeah it's got a stretch
exactly and a very small study that was
at that time was done it I think is what
two years ago showed because the
unfortunate thing about diastasis is
very under research it's very
under-researched is that 100% of women
are gonna get some degree of abdominal
separation by the end of the third
trimester right which makes it I mean
yeah very teeny I like this loop there's
also so much thing right so your body is
very smart
is gonna create the space that's
necessary for that baby to grow right
right but the thing is is when the baby
comes out the muscles don't hold feet
yeah just like the pelvic floor doesn't
go away right now you don't go we don't
leave the hospital this nice little take
now which then before unless you're you
know Prince Princess Kate Middleton of
course she was she had to get spanked I
don't think exactly and so the muscles
tend to stay somewhat separated but this
is when proper restorative exercises are
really important because if there's any
time for any spontaneous healing it's
typically your first eight weeks okay so
what we really recommend is wrapping the
abdominals right there's a big
difference between wrapping and wearing
a binder or corset right okay right
there's a big difference
yes corseting are binding where you
can't breathe you know what you actually
do is create a lot of internal pressure
down on the organs if the last thing you
want to do especially in recovery yes
because you've had enough pressure on
your organs with birth and with
pregnancy and all that stuff so you
don't want to do but you want a gentle a
gentle wrap something that you wrap from
the bottom up it just gives you that
gentle hug that's all you want and then
you do proper restorative exercises so
hopefully at the end of this eight weeks
that spontaneous healing time you go see
your pelvic floor physio and now you can
start doing a little bit more as far as
exercise but those first six to eight
weeks are really or doing proper
retraining before training begins six
months postpartum but if she had to have
died Stacy it doesn't necessarily mean
it's gone or my people leave recover
because everybody is different when
we're talking about abdominal separation
and everybody's recovery is different so
I'm just gonna walk you through how to
assess for a guy Stacy so again it's a
diastasis recti is separation of the
outer most abdominal muscles the rectus
abdominis and they start right up front
the ribcage and go all the way down to
the pubic bone okay so first of all I'm
gonna do is I'm going to take two
fingers and checking for toe cuz
remember was talking about that Linea
Alba that stretches now that the baby is
out it's also
piece of saran wrap right so I want to
see I should be able to keep the
integrity was it taught like before she
got pregnant or now it's a little bit
more loose I'm checking for tone and I'm
checking to see how deep my fingers go
in and it's right down the midline so
right from the ribcage I'm going all the
way down so she's got a pretty good tone
it gets a little bit weaker right around
the belly button which is totally normal
because this bigger circumference when
you're pregnant is run under belly
button that's where they check you
that's where they measure you right oh
yeah right so I'm gonna go down it gets
a little bit deeper right around the
belly button above and below and then
again it nice gets nice and taut right
around to the top of her pelvis so check
so I would say her tone is very good
just in a relaxed state she hasn't even
contracted or engaged fork or trying to
do any abdominal exercises so now I'm
gonna ask her to do again with two
fingers I'm asking her to keep her
abdominals relaxed you're gonna tuck in
your chin and slowly lift up your head
just a millimeter at a time he's coming
and I'm gonna ask him to stop when I
feel the muscles grab okay you're gonna
stop right there and I can feel the
muscles grabbing on either side beep
notice her head is quite high off the
floor put your head back down the reason
why I wouldn't consider that a proper
measurement is because we don't walk
around like this hmm
we walk around in an upright position so
I want to check and find out the
measurement just when she moves her head
off the floor I want to get it it's most
as upgrade as possible that means that's
even though she's lying down so I'm
gonna add another finger in so now I've
got three and I'm asking her keeper
abdominals relax tuck in your chin come
up nice and slow
and I'm gonna ask her stop please stop
right there okay so now I can feel the
muscles grabbing either side and go down
and I'm gonna try to add one more finger
and just see again so remember do not
contract your abdominals come up nice
and slow for me
stop and that fourth finger doesn't
really fit in so I would say she's a
three finger separation for your head
down down but here's the thing something
I want to stress the most current
research says the width of the the
rectus abdominus has no bearing on
function me so we do not care how wide
her rectus abdominus have separated
because we know that there's a very
normal part of pregnancy and you can
have someone who has five fingers
separation and has great tone like a B
but then have someone who has two
fingers separation and I can literally
go all the way down and I can feel their
organs
okay so it's not the great now if she
had two hands and I could fit two hands
which I've done before Wow I'd be
somewhat concerned and I want some
closure mm-hmm but it used to be so much
of we need to close the gap close the
gap which isn't necessarily the goal
anymore we want to be able to see that
she can create tension along that Linea
Alba and that she is functional okay so
the way now I would test it so I can say
she's a decent amount of tone just at
rest my fingers going a little bit
deeper like I said around the belly
button so now what a lot of people don't
know is that your transverse abdominus
their deepest abdominal muscle and her
pelvic floor muscles they're best
friends they actually quote contract
meaning when she doesn't pelvic floor
contraction her transverse abdominus are
gonna come on okay so I'm gonna put my
fingers just above her belly button
again she's gonna keep her abdominals
relaxed and I want you to do with Kegel
for me or any way that you've been
taught because she's seen a pelvic floor
physio she has been taught by her physio
how to do a proper Kegel and everybody
has told their own cue right I use
several cues the milkshake through a
straw with your vagina not your clitoris
but there's all kinds and everybody has
the old one do you want to share what
your cue is um I think it was like a
poppy seed like pick up a poppy seed so
she's gonna pick up a poppy seed with
her vagina not literally she's good
sucker
how do you see penny vagina vacuum
cleaner I'm gonna put my fingers back
here mm-hmm and I'm gonna ask you to do
a big inhale for me now I feel a little
bit more tension it's nice and taut here
as opposed to relaxed and then my
fingers sink in okay so that's pretty
cool so now I'm gonna ask her to do it
again so you're gonna do a big inhale
for me
exhale and want you to pick up that
poppy seed and now you're gonna tuck in
your chin and slowly lift up your head
and it almost feels like she has no
separation anymore because she's created
that tension or that stability from the
inside cool stuff hmm okay so let's talk
about some exercises okay great so the
first exercise really for all moms is
the core breath and it's an exercise you
do in an upright position because let's
not mince words right you have a baby
with us in the hospital or at home
you're getting up within the next 24
hours and you still have to live your
life right unless you're you're healing
for some [ __ ] but you have it a good
normal delivery this is what's gonna
happen but even before I do that though
I want to talk about alignment because
alignment is so important with this
particular exercise so we just want you
to look straight ahead and for those of
you who are watching you can see how
Abby's legs so she's a little bit jutted
forward and she's sitting she's standing
more on her mid foot and the balls of
her feet and she's leaning back a little
bit like this right and then you can see
that her boobies are pointed a little
bit upward and they're not down right so
the first thing I'm gonna ask Abby to do
is I want her to back up her weight and
I want you to take your perineum so
that's the space between your vagina and
your anus and I want you to bring that
space in between your ankles great now
all of a sudden look her shoulders are
stopped over her pelvis and the only
thing I asked her to do was to change
her alignment right here and then she's
gonna soften her ribs a little bit more
so she's gonna bring her ribs down but I
don't want you to I don't want you to
grieve and then the last thing I want
you to do is I want you to imagine
blossoming your butt cheeks all of a
sudden she gives herself a butt right so
for those months are saying I don't know
where's my butt go if all you do is just
change the way you stand with your
this Kim Kardashian but we don't want
her to also with we don't want her to
hyperextend her knees right so keep your
leg straight without hyperextending and
now she stacked much better her
shoulders over grips and now she's got a
bump okay so this is something to be
mindful of now she's gonna take this
proper alignment and she's gonna put it
in a chair so I'm just gonna bring this
chair over here
but she's not gonna walk like a statue
and I want you to sit down for me please
if you want to maintain the same
alignment so what I say to people when
they're sitting down is I want you to
pull the flesh away from your butt
cheeks so you're sitting on your sit
bones and your perineum so she should
feel the heaviness of the chair on her
perineum so this is proper alignment
seated and then I just showed you the
proper alignment standing and now I'm
gonna walk her sit through something
called the core breath so again talking
about that court for your diaphragm your
transverse your multifidus and your
pelvic floor we want to get all four
parts of that core working
synergistically together for optimal
core function and then she'll take that
core breathing in to all the other
restorative exercises I'm going to show
you afterwards so what I'm gonna do is
I'm just gonna place my hands around her
rooms actually you know what the
sentiment how do you do it okay you're
gonna take one hand and you're gonna put
on the side a rib cage and the other
hand you're gonna place on your belly
okay and what I want you to do is I want
you to take a big breath in and I want
you to breathe into both hands so
breathe sideways into your rib cage and
the overflow is gonna go into your belly
and then you exhale and bring your ribs
back down and your belly will naturally
draw in so inhale breathe sideways into
your rib cage and the overflow goes into
your belly exhale bring your ribs back
down and your your belly naturally draws
in great so continue to breathe like
this and then what I want you to do is I
want you to bring an awareness to your
pelvic floor so again what is your cue
for your pelvic floor the poppy seed the
poppy seed so what she's gonna do is
she's gonna inhale and expand and as she
exhales she's gonna Majan she's picking
up a poppy seed with her vagina
great you're gonna inhale let the poppy
see you go breathe sideways sideways
exhale pick up that poppy seeds and when
she's doing that she's actually creating
space between our perineum in the chair
and then she inhales like the poppy seed
go and now she's that she's melting over
the chair do one more exhale pick up
that poppy seed good inhale let it all
go and then the last step what she's
already doing is you're gonna exhale
which is exhaling imagine you're broke
blowing a candle out across the room
good inhale let the poppy seed go exhale
pick up your poppy seed blow that glow
with the candle and I know that's a lot
and for a first-time mom you're thinking
of opening up the ribs and picking up
poppy seeds and blowing out candles it
can be a lot so this is why I really
encourage everybody you are gonna do
whatever exercises work for you and
you're gonna go at your own pace but you
really want to master this core breath
one of the people who've been guilty of
staying absolutely no crunches if you
have a diastasis never do crunches again
the research has evolved crunches are
not a bad thing now crunches aren't
necessarily the most functional exercise
for a lot of people but what do new moms
do all the time especially new mom think
jackknife out of bed and the whole night
to go grab their babies so we need to
train them to be able to do that without
creating more pressure now if she
couldn't create good function and we see
any doming then absolutely I would not
give her crunches okay crunches are only
something I would do once you're at
Abby's state where she can actually
maintain tension she did a curl up which
is basically a mini crunch and
everything was nice and taut but if I
saw any doming at all I would say no
you're not ready to do that yet and I
would continue to tell her to roll on
her side to get up and end down okay so
because we want to avoid any doping you
also want to avoid domaine during
pregnancy as well
after you've had a baby because you're
connected to she's been stretched so
much really the only thing now between
me and your organs is connective tissue
any thought right so basically what
you're doing is you're pushing
everything from the inside out and
you're exacerbating that connected
tician you're exacerbating that
separation we don't want to do that we
want to create home one you maintain
that so until we can do that we don't
want to keep pushing it because it's
counterintuitive to what we're trying to
do right right so now it's she was
somebody if I if you were I was working
with you then I would say yes you could
do crunches but not two hundred crunches
of 300 crunches you want to have a
variety we use our bodies like this we
use our body like your how many times
sit in the car your life
trying to put the sooner and yeah Mary
you want to work transverse do you want
to work lateral you because you're
bending over doing this so you would do
all kinds of different abdominal
exercises but I first always want to
make sure that you can clean that
stability and that tension from the
inside okay you got it someone else
might also if they're feeling any
pressure in their pelvis they might do a
crunch or a head lift and they'll feel
more pressure is the pressure have to go
somewhere diastasis is basically it's
caused by mismanagement of
intra-abdominal pressure look if the
baby's pushing all the time you've got
constant pressure here your eventually
your abdominals go right and then the
pressure goes down on the pelvic floor
so if you're doing crunches and say you
don't see any domain by oh but I'm
feeling more pressure and my pelvis or
I'm starting to leak right stuff has to
go somewhere then that's another sign
that you're not ready to do crunches or
any head looks like this cotton
once you've mastered the core breath is
you're gonna do a bridge and I love the
bridge it's an inversion exercise
because what has happened to all your
organs during pregnancy and birth those
organs have been pushed down push down
push down and again if when I was
talking about the leaders testing
diastasis the last thing is you want to
create more pressure if anything we want
to put the organs back to where they are
so lying here with your legs bent what
the only thing I would ask you to do now
is so you're gonna take that pelvic
floor cue that you have picking up a
poppy seed and now you're going to take
that poppy seeds and put it the opening
of your anus mmm okay so now we're
working the backside so we're working
your your back muscles here we're
working your glutes and your hamstrings
and what I'm gonna ask you to do is
you're going to take a big inhale and as
you exhale you've got that poppy seed
with your anus and now you're gonna lift
and then inhale and come on down and let
it all go
again exhale yourself up exhale pick up
your poppy seed with your anus and lift
good inhale let the poppyseed go down as
you come on down
exercise I'm going to go over with you
it's a clamshell because not only if
your abdominals may be separated and
you're dealing with some some pelvic
some pelvic health issues our glutes
tend to become inhibited during
pregnancy Tony and then what I'm gonna
ask you to do is I'm gonna take you to
ask you to take a big inhale so you're
gonna inhale and expand into the rib
cage and I'm you exhale I want you to do
your pelvic floor contraction then
you're gonna lift your knee and keep
your ankles together and you're gonna
lift as high as you can without rotating
your spine and you should feel your
glutes right clapping good already and
then you're gonna inhale let it all go
to expand into ribcage exhale do your
pelvic floor contraction lift your knee
great and the last exercise and this
again is just for the early stages
you're just slowly getting things moving
as I would say this is the this is more
Diane Stacy specific but again you're
always incorporating that core breath
that I showed you in the beginning with
every exercise okay so what you're gonna
do is you're gonna take a big hand Hale
and expand exhale I want you to pick up
your poppy seed and as you're exhaling
you're gonna slide one leg out good now
you're gonna inhale let it all go expand
exhale pick up your poppy seed and slide
your leg back in and the reason you're
doing this movement during the exhale is
because remember when I even when I did
the diastasis assessment you created all
of this tension we want to maintain the
tension during the movement so the more
more we can set your brain to maintain
tension during movement its motor
patterning and the more it will start
happening on its own okay so for those
who are watching don't think that now
forever every time you do something you
have to but they look inhale exhale
doing a Kegel before you move this is
all in preparatory so when you do go
back to normal exercise your body just
does it that did you've created that
system okay so everyone I hope you guys
enjoyed this video and found it as
information packed and enlightening as I
definitely did thank you so much Sam for
joining me today well show me all these
great
moves I feel like you know I'm
definitely on a better path for that
pelvic floor recovery awesome and Sam
tell us if people want to get a little
bit more information where can they find
you well you can find me on Instagram or
Facebook i'm known as Sam core trainer
but my website is Sam core trainer.com
and I've got also all kinds of great
exercises and resources but if you want
to work directly with me just send me a
message and my website and I'll get you
all set up guys amazing well guys I hope
you enjoyed this be sure to give this
video a thumbs up leave me a comment
below letting me know if you guys saw a
pelvic floor therapist or if you're
planning to I'd love to hear from you
also subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]